The answer is 11ab squared c, plus 3ab,
plus 9abc squared, plus 4c.
We can simplify this the same way
that we did in the previous example.
Let's find all the like terms and
combine them.
Ab squared c and
10ab squared c are like terms.
And it looks like there
are no other like terms, so
everything else can stay how it is,
and we'll just rearrange these so
the like terms are next to each other.
So after a bit of rearranging, we get
ab squared c, plus 10ab squared c,
plus 3ab, plus 9abc squared, plus 4c.
Now we can combine our like terms, which
are ab squared c and 10ab squared c.
Note that if there is no coefficient
shown in front of a variable,
the coefficient is implied to be 1.
So ab squared c,
actually equals one ab squared c.
That means that when we combine
10ab squared c, with ab squared c,
we're actually combining 10ab squared c,
with one ab squared c.
Which gives us 11ab squared c.
We can't combine any coefficients for
these other terms, so
they just stay how they are.
And our final answer is 11ab squared c,
plus 3ab, plus 9abc squared, plus 4c.
[BLANK_AUDIO]